When joining panels of knitting, instead
of trying to hide the seam, draw attention
to it.
Our knitting machines limit us to the
number of stitches we can knit at a time.
So sometimes we have to add
a seam on a garment piece.
For example, the Knit it Now
Basics patterns for larger sizes.
Calculate a full back of
a cardigan into pieces.
Now you may be an expert finisher, but I
dunno about you, stitching up a seam down
the center back of a
sweater really annoys me.
Instead of hiding the seam, why
not make it a design element?
You may be familiar with
a hairpin lace join.
We often use this to join blanket panels
and this'll work for your sweater, but
there are so many more things you can do.
How about letting that seam show on the
public side of your garment and just join
it with single crochet.
You'll place the wrong sides together and
single crochet through half a stitch on
each edge of your knitting.
You don't crochet, hang both sides on
the machine with the wrong or the private
sides together.
Hang half a stitch and bind off
fairly loosely around the gate pegs.
You can always knit the second
panel with a sew-as-you-go method.
But try it with your yarn and
your stitch pattern first.
If your stitch pattern is very textured,
this might blend in beautifully and it'll
save you finishing that seam.
Let's really draw attention
to the scene in this sample.
I transferred the second stitch to the
third every other row creating an eyelet.
In other words, I left a seaming stitch in
work and transfer this stitch next to it
to form an eyelet on the edge.
When I knit the adjoining piece, I simply
hung these eyelets on the edge needle
every other row joining the two pieces.
This time as I joined that eyelet edge.
Like before I created an eyelett on the
joining piece, creating two columns of
eyelets along the edge.
Now take this idea one step further.
Use your three prong transfer tool and
create a full fashion transfer to decorate
this eyelet edge even more.
As you create the eyelets on working this
technique, make sure that the emptied
needle is back in working
position each time.
Maybe I'm getting carried away, but
putting a needle out of work adds even
more interest.
Hmm.
Let's think we could put some
eyelets along that edge as well.
Play with this technique.
I'm sure you'll come up with something
that will decorate that seam and you'll be
proud to wear a seam down the
middle of the back of your sweater.